[Applause]
presidential candidate and former rebel
gustavo petras galvanized millions
especially young voters by promising to
change this deeply unequal country
twenty-year-old stephanie ramirez
decided to volunteer for petra's
campaign after she was unable to pay for
her college during the pandemic and her
parents struggled to keep their small
shop open
it's been very difficult as a young
colombian to live in such precarious
conditions when it comes to work and
access to health and education and i
believe that petro is betting on
changing all of this
[Music]
last year she joined tens of thousands
of other young colombians to protest
against living conditions
they were some of the most violent
demonstrations colombia has seen in
decades
the police crackdown only inflamed the
discontent of those outraged by the
country's widening inequality
is before the protests had been very
inactive politically but with all the
injustices and killings i could not
remain indifferent it evoked the desire
for things to be different for us
peter is backed by many poor and working
class colombians but viewed with alarm
by businessmen and some middle class
voters they fear as plans to halt new
oil development or redistribute pension
funds could put economic stability at
risk
this letter sent by the manager of one
of the biggest milk companies in the
country urging suppliers not to vote for
petro went viral last week
it says petro would put at risk private
property and the freedom of enterprise
in the country a petrol clause has also
been added to a number of contracts this
year allowing the parties to scrap the
deal if the former geria comes to power
mario hernandez who runs one of the best
known colombian fashion houses is not
hiding his support for petra's main
rival federico gutierrez who is seen as
a continuation of business-friendly
policies of president ivan duque
i prefer the devil i know i've said it
many times in south america the left has
never been successful from cuba downward
that's the example
but with more than 20 million people
living in poverty and rising violence
polls show that 70 percent of colombians
want change not all of them believe
peter's proposals are the right ones but
enough people could decide to give him
and the left a chance alessandra
ampietti al jazeera bogota